hey guys and welcome to episode number
seven of my GE only challenge uh thank
you guys for watching through the last
six episodes uh the support on the
series has been awesome uh so now where
are we standing as of the last episode
well we're pretty close uh to 600 total
level our cash stack is getting very
close to the 10 mil uh Mark I think
after this episode and at the start of
the next one I'll have it now you guys
mentioned that I shouldn't really buy
the construction skill as soon as I have
10 mil and you're correct on that one uh
So the plan is at the start of the next
episode I am going to do some flipping
in between them and just get my money uh
past 10 mil a little bit now what's
going to happen with the 10 mil is I'm
going to be giving it away uh as part of
a giveaway but anyway yeah so if you
guys want to enter of the giveaway leave
a comment on why you think uh you should
get the money and what you want to do
with it as well as make sure you're
subscribe to my channel and toss the
video like if you are enjoying the
series again thank you so much for
watching all the way through and let's
get started uh so to kick things off I
have flipped a couple of these Zam Gods
sword ornament kits I have bought three
of them so far uh one for 1.3 mil and
two of them for 1.4 mil uh which you
can't see the other one unfortunately uh
but we're looking to sell them for uh 1
5 mil or 1,550 k so on one of them we're
going to profit about 250k and on the
other two we're going to get about uh
200k on so really good flips looking to
make about 600 to 700k in total off of
just three items another thing we've
done quickly is I combined another 7500
item in bolts and Diamond bolts but we
ended up messing up the margin so we
actually lost 126k on there by accident
uh but it's not a huge deal okay so
someone in my last episode mentioned
that I had a lot of easy firemaking
levels to gain and they're correct we
just hit 35 fir making uh just from
burning Willows and now we can burn te
logs although I'm not sure if I'm going
to do it yet because they are a little
more pricey and I am trying to save as
much as money as possible uh for the 10
mil all right that changed my mind uh it
was only like 100k to get uh enough te
logs to get to 45 fir making and I think
I was thinking of the mahogany logs
which are quite a bit more expensive uh
te aren't too bad but there's 40 fir
making all right we're just about to hit
45 fir making there we go now we can
burn Maple logs which is great because
Maple logs are dirt cheap uh they're
great for Fletching great for fir making
but yeah they're only nine coins each so
really not a huge investment there okay
we're just about to hit level 50 fir
making uh one thing I'm actually looking
forward to trying is once I get my wood
cutting to 60 uh trying the infernal axe
with getting the fir making experience
might be good although I might want to
go past 60 before I start cutting use
but since my choice is between oak trees
and UT trees I'm not sure how much
difference there is in experience rates
so I'm excited to try that out so since
I'm looking to continue training my
skills but I also want to make money
that kind of eliminates quite a few of
the buyable skills uh luckily Fletching
is still profitable even uh at this
level and this experience rate so what
we've bought is uh 2,000 uh U long bows
unstr strong as well as 2K bow strings
uh and I think we're going to profit
about 200k an hour doing this plus
actually really good experience uh so
we'll give us a try okay we're just
about to hit the Fletching level just
from string these U long bows uh there
is 72 Fletching now we can make a heavy
ballista if I wanted to I'm not sure if
I'd ever want to do that though all
right we're just finishing up the long
bows and we're actually going to hit
another Fletching level it's going to be
73 Fletching uh which now allows us to
make Onyx tipped bolts which I never
have tried before I feel like it' be too
expensive even if it was profitable uh
but we'll just finish up the bow strings
and see how much we actually profit from
this okay so we sold them off for
665 and so that's 1.3 mil and we bought
the prerequisites for about 1 M72 coins
or 72k sorry so that's about a 200 and
250k profit uh which is not bad that
took me just over an hour hour to do so
about 200 to 250k an hour all right here
is another Fletching level we are making
the push for 75 Fletching but there's 74
for now uh we're just pretty much doing
this while waiting for the flips to come
through I'm actually really enjoying
Fletching uh so nothing to complain
about money and a good experience is
always nice okay there is 75 Fletching
uh just another quick Milestone I don't
think we actually unlock anything
worthwhile just Rune arrows uh we still
have to do youu long bows all the way
till 80 at which point we can make magic
short bows uh I don't think magic short
bows are profitable but I think by the
time uh we get there I don't think I'll
be as interested in making sure I'm
profiting off of Fletching I could lose
some money just for some quicker
experience rates and I think we sold off
the last uh godsword ornament kit as
well okay so we're going to take a break
from the Fletching grind and we're going
to go actually train a bit of attack so
we got all the way to 40 attack uh just
off of guards once again I don't think
we're going to go much past 40 uh again
because we will unlock the M Giants
eventually uh but yeah the experience is
pretty bad here only about 15K 20K an
hour all right there is a crafting level
we are still making these unpowered orbs
which we're going to do until we have
the money uh to do anything else pretty
much uh cuz right now it's only about
100K 150k GP an hour to do this and
we're getting about 80k crafting
experience okay we're just about to hit
60 crafting and I think that's where
we're going to stop for now uh I think
once we get a ton of money on our
account we're going to spend a lot of
money on Crafting uh right now I
obviously don't have it but this is
going to be a money making account I
should theoretically have loads of money
at certain points uh so yeah I'm just
going to do unpowered orbs but
eventually we could do air battle stabs
Green Dragon hide okay we're just about
to hit Level 52 wood cutting and I'm
actually really impressed by how quickly
uh oak trees gives you experience it's
about 30 to 35k experience an hour and I
think that's probably better in new
trees while I'm going to try them out
when I hit 60 I feel like you trees are
going to be slower okay we have a couple
flips coming in for the darkness set
items uh uh now we bought a lot of stuff
in between so we don't have the exact
amount but uh the Robes of Darkness we
sold for 223 each and we bought them for
198 uh so it's about a 25k profit in
each one uh 10 of those gives us 250k in
profit we also have the boots of
darkness and the gloves of Darkness uh
which we'll go over a bit later when
they're sold but we are going to put
another offer in for the gloves of
Darkness cuz I can tell you right now we
bought them for 83k each and we're
selling them for 139 which is just
exceedingly good uh I think we have
flipped five or six of these so far as
well we're back at the good old oak
trees uh just hit 53 wood cutting we're
watching The League of Legends champion
Series in the background uh so we're
powering out some wood cutting levels
and uh yeah pretty happy with the
progress all right we're just about to
hit another wood cutting level and I
think that's all we're going to do for
now that is going to be 55 wood cutting
only five more levels until we can
finally cut U trees and I'm really
excited to try out the infernal Axe and
yeah there's 55 okay so we have a lot of
stuff going on in the grand exchange
right now
uh but one thing I'm looking forward to
trying right now is uh leveling up my
cooking using wines I thought it was an
extremely expensive method of leveling
but it really not uh it's only about 250
300K GP per hour but the amount of
experience you can get is like 400k
upwards of 500k an hour it's just
ridiculous and I'm just looking forward
to giving it a try I'm not going to do
too much now cuz again I'm trying to
save money but we're bought 1,000 wines
and let's give it a shot so the way
wines work work is they're on like a
time delay fuse uh so you see I just got
a 40K experience drop you don't get the
experience until you've stopped making
wines for I think 12 seconds uh so there
we go we just hit 55 cooking All in One
XP drop which is just crazy I think
these wines should get us to 60 though
uh but yeah this actually really fun I
like it all right I messed up I try to
go all the way to 60 but I sometimes you
just kind of mess up your clicks and uh
what another 50k experience drop is not
bad brings us to 57 cooking and I guess
we'll do the last 50k drop which will
get us to 60 but yeah sometimes you mess
up the wines and I started freaking out
I just hit the recorder button and so at
least I captured it okay this should
bring us all the way to 60 cooking last
XP drop is going to be 15K and there is
60 cooking I am really looking forward
to doing this it's only about 7 mil all
the way to 99 so once I have some money
I'm definitely just going to go ahead
and get 99 cooking okay I'm going to
update you on some flips that just
happened uh a little messy but I can
declutter it for you so to start off uh
the gloves of Darkness we ended up
getting a 56k margin on and we got 10 of
them sold them in two chunks for 139k so
56k and 10 of those gives us a 560k
profit on the gloves alone which is
awesome uh the boots of Darkness we
ended with a 11k margin on giving us
133k in total although it's not on my
history anymore and the uh robe top of
Darkness we ended with a 40K margin uh
time 7 gives us 280k or in total about 1
mil in profit which is awesome the
darkness set has always been good to
flip and it holds true now uh so as part
of trying to hit that 10 mil Mark cuz we
ended up with 8.2 mil cash uh I'm going
to go ahead and combine some Ruby bolt
tips this time uh Diamond bolts are not
profitable right now but this is the
only thing I could think of that would
give me money and train my skills so
we'll go do 10k of these okay we sold
them off for 357 each I think we only
profited about uh 150k on these not a
whole lot okay so we managed to buy 20
of the obsidian shields uh or the totic
Kell uh now they actually have a really
crazy margin on them right now uh 225
and I think we bought them for
198 uh so we're going to give a try to
sell these off uh it's a bit of a risk
cuz I bought them at what is kind of a
higher price uh well I guess 197 it's a
little bit higher than they're normally
at but still that is a
20 K profit pretty much on each one uh
so we're looking to make 400k on these
20 Shields which is just great okay
we're back and we did manage to sell
everything off in our grand exchange
which is nice so we can see how much
money we have in total it's going to be
pretty close to 10 mil now like I said
we made 400k on the shields on the
gloves we managed to profit 300K uh
which is awesome the top only gave us a
30k profit uh well 35 but still pretty
happy with the rest of the flips here
you can see the gloves we got for 600k
sold them for for 900 uh the Tucket
skill Butch that pretty hard and uh
anyway 400k on that uh we're going to
probably go ahead and buy some more of
these we're going to recheck the margin
still 225 into 186 that is crazy uh
sorry 210 into 186 that's still really
good so we'll go ahead and put an offer
in for 186 and we're going to max out
our money here we have 9.2 mil so we're
getting so close to that 10 mil Mark uh
but we'll do 45 for now and leave us a
little money left over Okay so just
upgraded to a rune citar since we just
got 40 attack I think we're going to go
bang out 40 defense so we can actually
upgrade our armor as well okay we're
back at the guard just training up our
defense levels uh really quick with this
Rune citaro it increased our Max hit to
11 I believe uh but there's 35 defense
only five more then we can wear Rune
armor okay we just hit 45 hit points
another nice Milestone uh we'll be able
to tank the Moss giant hits a bit better
uh once we actually unlock the area but
yeah we're going for 40 defense a we
should get it pretty soon okay so I did
end up selling all 45 of the obsidian
shields uh but since uh the price was
changing a lot I ended up having to
change the price when we were selling
them at uh so we'll go ahead and
calculate it quickly because I
personally don't even know how much
money I made off this flip so I'll start
by adding up all the prices that we sold
them at so 528 9k plus 12 54k plus
2460 uh so we sold them for pretty much
99 mil in total and we'll subtract what
we bought them for 4 which was
8370 and
188k which will leave me with a 445k
profit which is pretty good okay so we
ended up getting two Genie lamps I'm
just putting them in thieving for now
cuz I don't actually know anything else
that would be worthwhile to put it in
kind of thinking agility maybe uh but
for now we'll just see if we can get a
thie level just off the experience lamps
okay I just hit 40 defense and now I can
wear the Rune armor set except for the
Rune plate body unfortunately can't wear
that
but I'll just sub in the Rune chain body
for now and then eventually I guess I
can upgrade it later okay we got our
full Rune Set uh it looks a little
cheesy with the Rune chain body but what
are you going to do I'm not sure what
else I could substitute it for right now
uh but let's see what our defensive
bonus gets up by so we're starting with
uh 162 stab 171 and some Crush bonus and
increase
nice kite Shield increases it by a lot
and the chain body definitely has a much
higher slash and Crush
uh so I think it's worth it even though
we're losing two stab defense which is
not that big a deal but yeah finally got
our Rune Armor All Right the most
exciting point of this episode is always
uh grinding the agility levels there's
six agility uh just using these toy mice
I think the agility is going to cap it
at about 2k XP per hour but I mean
agility sucks anyway so it's not even
that much worse who am I joking is
definitely like 10 to 20 times worse
than regularly training agility but I
had a look at the uh jelly shortcut
which is 46 I would need with a plus
five boost and that is going to require
22,000 toy mice to be picked up which is
going to take like 20 to 30 hours which
is pretty much like a 99 okay we're just
about to hit another agility level there
is level 7 agility and I'm not sure if
these summer pies are helping out very
much but they are giving me a plus five
boost which does let you pick up the
mice quicker so we'll continue using
them all right there's level eight
agility I'm going to go for two more
today and now we could grapple across
rther River Lum if I ever wanted to I
don't think there's any other agility
shortcut here that's going to be useful
uh besides the verac GE one but that
doesn't give me any experience so it's
kind of pointless okay level 9 agility
now I've changed my setup a little bit
so you can see here I have a bunch of
Summer pies so my toy mice will be
funneled right back in the inventory
like this and then it's a little easier
to release them like this uh so I guess
I'm slowly getting the meta for toy mice
I'm not sure what everyone else does
when they pick up their toy mice but
this is what I'm doing
okay I think this is going to be the
last level I can do right now there is
level 10 agility nice Milestone to stop
at and we can now use the drainer course
but uh we're too good to use that we're
going to continue doing the
mice all right guys I think that's where
we're going to end the episode for today
so now I'm going to start with the recap
so how much money do I have it looks
like I have around 9.4 mil plus 1.3
which is going to bring me to over 10
mil uh maybe a bit less because I think
I did claim a couple of these earlier
but still definitely past the 10 mil uh
cash amount so uh in between this
episode and the next episode I'm going
to do some flipping uh but don't forget
I am going to be giving away that 10 mil
to a lucky viewer all you got to do is
leave a comment on this video and um
toss it a like I mean just toss a like
if you enjoyed it and if you're
subscribed you will have a chance of
winning the 10 mil now as for the stats
that we gained this episode uh looks
like what has changed let's start from
the left looks like I gained five attack
levels uh 10 defense levels which is
awesome now I can wear the Rune Armor
Set uh nothing else there uh we got up
to 45 hit points which is good just for
tanking some more hits uh five agility
levels of course grinding that away uh
five crafting levels and I think four
Fletching levels we're up to 75
Fletching now and another noticeable one
is the 10 cooking which I got from wines
which is awesome uh and five wood
cutting levels so in total I gained 63
total levels this episode which is not
bad plus uh for the next episode I will
be able to get the 750 required uh for
unlocking the next area fairly easily I
mean if you look 40 construction levels
uh 30 farming levels that's already up
to 700 total plus we can just find an
extra 50 total levels um pretty easily
so I think I'll be able to hit it pretty
soon so thanks a lot guys for watching I
hope you enjoyed and I'll see you guys
in episode number
[Music]
eight